[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that trailer for the new one looks like
it might even be good it's acknowledging
harold ramus's passing
looks like he's being more clever with
its callbacks
as long as it doesn't call back to the
second movie that
that wouldn't be good what if it does
though
and even if it doesn't what if people
start re-watching the second movie again
what if people discover it for the first
time what what if
what if they think ghostbusters 2
is good
nah that wouldn't happen
what if the movie actually was good
[Applause]
[Music]
though
nobody likes every movie they see
there's plenty of reasons for that
maybe it's got a miscast central role
maybe the editing
really breaks the flow maybe the writing
is just plain crap
but those kinds of things usually just
mean that you don't like
a movie in order to hate a movie
it has to do more than be bad it has to
hurt you and when it comes to
entertainment
few things hurt like seeing something
you love
get completely screwed up
now depending on the kind of person you
are that can sometimes leave you
in a bit of a conundrum because
the component parts are things you enjoy
or at least you
once enjoyed before just the end result
was a disaster and sometimes for me
rarely but sometimes you want to figure
out how
to fix it so
let's fix ghostbusters 2.
ghostbusters is my favorite movie of all
time period
full stop not saying it's the best movie
but it is
my favorite and it has been for most of
my life
and ghostbusters 2 was one of the first
movies i remember
not liking even the very first time i
saw it
the true hate of it would build over
time but even that
first viewing at the tender age of seven
something felt off i i just couldn't
have told you what not back then
but now it's more than 30 years later
and while i may not hold a degree in
anything i know enough about how stories
get told to understand
why i hate it if everything you're doing
is bad
i want you to know this and against my
better judgment
i'm gonna try and fix it
we're gonna need a different setup for
this
all right couple of ground rules here
first
i'm not rewriting this thing from the
ground up if you want a full script for
me completely fleshed out somebody write
me a check
what this is going to be about is using
the existing
components and basic structure of the
film as it currently
is and then refining reworking
and tweaking all the component parts so
that we end up with something that isn't
so
utterly disappointing so
let's actually talk about the problems
that we are working on here starting
with
i'm starting to think maybe i should
have gotten a proper pointer
you work with what you own problem
number one
the needless reset at the start of the
film the key characters have all gone
their separate ways and
aren't where we left them instead of
building on the foundation
of the first movie the sequel instead
blows it up in order to rebuild
virtually the same foundation
from scratch all over again this is
honestly the single biggest problem with
the movie and nearly everything that we
have to correct
stems from this in many ways the minds
behind ghostbusters
didn't fully appreciate how finely tuned
the balance of comedy action and sci-fi
horror was
in that first film and when it came to
the sequel the makers approached it in
the way that hollywood usually
approaches comedy sequels
which is to do the exact same thing
again now as big a problem as this is
unfortunately we can't actually fix it
properly because
ideally this just wouldn't be the case
at all
but it's too fundamental to how the film
plays out for me to be able to
completely
chuck it then i'd just be violating rule
one and rewriting the whole thing from
the ground up
so what we need is we need to find a way
to make this
very stupid decision somehow work
problem number two too many repeated
beats from the first film
as a result of problem number one the
overall structure of this film is
virtually identical
to the original which makes it feel
repetitive lazy
and predictable the team has to form all
over again peter has to woo dana again
significant elements with the new york
don't think the ghostbusters are for
real
again they get locked up at the behest
of a petty tyrant of a bureaucrat
again oh but it's in an asylum this time
which is
totally different and all while an
ancient evil is building towards its
return to the earthly plane
again as with the first problem
we're kind of stuck with this to a
certain extent so it's gonna be a
correction by degrees
if we can just nudge things in
one direction or another so it's at
least a little
different from the first film that might
be enough to make it not feel like such
a retread
problem number three characters without
a purpose
we'll get into this more when i do a
full character breakdown but the film
goes out of its way to bring back nearly
every named character from the first
film
and the ones that it didn't bring back
it comes up with direct equivalence for
as a result we have several characters
who had function in the first film
who don't really have a place in this
one louis tully is the big one
since his role in the first film is now
effectively taken over by janish
yet lewis himself is still here but it
also affects janine
and even some of the main characters to
lesser degrees
problem number four lame villain
vigo isn't a total loss as a villain but
he's hampered by the fact that
well he's just a guy part of what was
great about gozer
is we didn't really know what it was
even when we saw it we knew there was
something
else going on beyond what we were seeing
whatever it wants to be figo may have
some impressive powers but he's still
just a dude or at least he was
originally
according to the backstory we get and
it's what he looks like now that makes
him more
comprehensible and less interesting and
as a sub problem of this the fact that
he's stuck in the painting for pretty
much the whole film
is also an issue yes it's true gosu
didn't show up until the end of the
first one
but there was all this heralding and
wonder of what it even would
be here we know what viggo is
he's right there in the painting you
would think
that having his presence established
earlier than goser would be an asset but
it's not
when he's so static problem number
five unsatisfying climax
the build up with the statue of liberty
isn't half bad much as it's trying to
recapture the iconography of the state
puff marshmallow man
however the actual final confrontation
with viggo is pretty lackluster
because vigo isn't much of a physical
threat because of how static he is
he kind of leaves the painting briefly
after janis is doused but
it's weird and the threat is very vague
it lacks
punch it lacks
yeah that past these big points there's
minor tweaks that we'll touch on as we
go along but these are the five
big hurdles let's take a look at a
structure on this thing shall we
now we're going to be leaving most of
this
intact the film's core structure is
actually really simple and as i said i'm
going to be altering it as little as
possible so here's the major plot beats
the ghostbusters aren't working together
anymore so we have to establish where
everyone
is there's a new evil rising and is tied
to dana peter needs to reconnect with
her looking into the new evils lands the
ghostbusters in
legal trouble which means that we also
get to learn about the mood slime at
this point
the business gets reestablished the
heroes get stalled by bureaucrats
viggo kidnaps oscar statue of liberty
pump up the city rescue the kid beat the
bad guy
woo we win so like i said we're keeping
most of that intact
i don't love it let's be clear but like
i said rewriting this thing from scratch
it's not the idea so let's take it from
the top
the starting setup
okay so the first thing we need to do is
deal with the fact that the ghostbusters
aren't ghost busting this whole initial
premise causes a lot of the problems
we're going to be dealing with and it
means that the first half hour or so
shares the somewhat leisurely pace of
the original film
but it worked there because the first
film had well
it had a way stronger opener and then
got away with slower build of them
starting the business
and their first client because all of
this was new
and novel in and of itself it's not
anymore
we've seen it we know what they're like
working together we know what their
jobs look like and delaying that isn't
build up it's stalling
but as i said the ghostbusters not being
active at the start of the movie
it's too big a piece to cut if i ditch
that it's got such a massive ripple
effect that
it breaks the whole exercise so we're
going to massage
that idea so it works better and we're
going to deal with some characters to
illustrate how
as presented the start of the film gives
us egon running fairly mundane
experiments on emotional
response rey running on occult bookstore
peter having parlayed himself into a bit
of a z-list celebrity host of a
psychic-focused tv show
and winston okay honestly we don't know
what winston is up to
he shows up at the kids party with rey
but that could have been him just doing
ray a favor
and it doesn't seem like it would be
lucrative enough to actually be paying
his
bills actually i just want to highlight
that the movie as it exists does a
massive
disservice to winston as a character
seriously he's even left out of the big
re-shooting scene in the courtroom so
you better believe
we're getting him in on that dana and
peter apparently broke up for some
reason and in the interim she got with
another guy
had a kid split with that guy so she can
now be single
for peter to hit on again yeah we'll
come back to that
that's sort of our five main core cast
but we've also got
returning the mayor janine and lewis and
also slimer but whatever the mirror
is actually used perfectly fine ignoring
the ghostbusters until he needs them
it's true to his original
characterization and frankly
it doesn't need to be changed janine and
lewis okay
so these two hook up because the movie
brought them back without knowing what
to do with them and somehow
this was the only thing they could think
of and it's stupid
and pointless and i hate it and because
this very stupid ship doesn't actually
impact anything
we're just not gonna do it i've got a
plan for what to do with lewis but for
now janine and egon
will be together like they're supposed
to be
don't even argue with me on that it's
the natural progression of where they
were headed
at the end of the previous film also
we're giving janine her fashion sense
back because what the hell even is this
okay so the in universe reason that the
characters
start out the way they do is because the
business
is effectively dead and as much as i
don't like this
i have to admit that as far as the
internal logic of the films goes
it actually does make sense the first
film did point out
pretty strongly that gozer's impending
arrival was a big part of what was
driving supernatural activity up
that's the point that this scene was
making that's a big twinkie
so with gozer taken care of it would
make sense
that some things tapered off the sequel
adds an additional hurdle in the form of
a legal injunction
barring them from engaging in ghost
busting at all
this detail serves no purpose not even
to get them in legal trouble
because they were already breaking
numerous laws
in their investigations of the mood
slime that's plenty to get us to the
courtroom scene
the injunction adds nothing and we're
chucking it
so now what we'll do is we'll say
business died doubt on its own
in a way that happens in the real world
the demand isn't there so the business
goes
soft which gives us a much better way to
bring lewis into the story
at present the ghostbusters hire lewis
as their lawyer
louis the guy who was only shown to be
an accountant in the previous film
yes he says he only knows tax law but
using this as a way to bring him into
the story is convoluted
contrived and it also makes the heroes
look like absolute
idiots for not getting a proper lawyer
and don't tell me they can't afford
better than lewis all of them have jobs
that pay their bills and between them
they can pay for better than this
because one time i turned into a dog and
they helped me
thank you
so here's how we're going to kill two
birds with one stone the business died
down but it's not
completely dead it's just the
supernatural activity went back to its
normal background level which doesn't
need the full team
or really much of anybody by the time
the film was going to start janine any
calls
no any messages
any customers no dr venkman
but what about those precious franchise
rights that peter was so excited about
the franchise rights alone will make us
rich beyond our wildest dreams
do you really think he'd let this whole
thing completely die on the vine
no not a chance and remember what lewis
asked the team at the end of the first
film
who does your taxes so now the backstory
is lewis was actually hired as their
on-staff accountant and is basically the
only in-office employee left since
janine will rarely bother to come in
anymore
because the phone never rings and louis
is there to make sure the books are kept
that the business still exists at
minimal costs
and that the trademarks don't lapse it
fits who he
is is way more organic to his character
honestly he doesn't really need to be
here at all but if he's going to be here
this is how we're going to do it so
that's the state of the business
now let's talk about the other
characters rey and egon honestly
we can leave them where the movie puts
them because it makes sense in both
cases
well almost the shift to behavioral
science that egon undergoes feels
a bit off i buy he's involved in
non-ghost related experiments but
i'd have expected him to be in a lab
looking through a microscope but a mold
sample
i collect spores molds and fungus but
even though i'd like to i'm not actually
going to make that change because
him studying emotions does feed into the
mood slime later on or
at least it should but the movie as is
actually doesn't connect those dots
anyways we'll keep the emotional study
for egon but we're also going to briefly
establish that it's not the kind of
science he prefer to be doing
maybe just have him uh give him a quick
bit of dialogue with janine since
remember there are a couple now and
we'll have him do more to link back to
it later when he's working on the mood
slime oh and we're scrapping the entire
children's party at the front end
establishing the ghostbusters as a joke
within the world isn't funny it doesn't
add anything that the business going
quiet doesn't already do
and most importantly of all i personally
hate it if we're truly desperate for a
misdirect
we can have you know what we can have
winston call ray and ray's all
super excited that what they might find
until they realize that somebody's
cat got in a crawl space is just making
noise or something
whistling can complain to ray needs to
stop calling him for this stuff ray can
be all apologetic because he just gets
so
excited when he thinks maybe things are
gonna pick back up again but the big
thing
is if we do this it'll be done quickly
and we're not going to humiliate them
for two and a half
minutes like the existing film does
peter hosting this tv show it's totally
the kind of second career he tried to
springboard into so
we're not really gonna mess with that
though we're gonna trim the scenes
related to it by about 30 percent at
least
because they are not as funny as the
filmmakers thought they were
the big change we're going to do on
peter
is that he and dana are still together
and oscar
is his kid the funny thing is this
actually doesn't change as much of the
movie as you'd think
i tend to assume that the writers broke
these two up between movies because they
wanted that flirty cording banter again
now i don't know why hollywood keeps
insisting that happily married couples
can't have flirty
banter and can't keep the fun alive in a
relationship but that's wrong
if you want to put a little relationship
tension in there we can have a bit
here or there about how peter seems more
interested in trying to recapture
his fading fame than by spending time
with his kid
but let's not overdo that because
ultimately we don't actually need to
change the dynamic we see in the film
all that much and as a bonus it gives
peter
better non-selfish motives and an actual
personal stake in things because one of
the things that bugged the heck out of
me
about ghostbusters 2 was how casual the
film
feels about the danger while it's
threatening
a helpless baby the sillier vibes give
me tonal whiplash whenever it goes back
to oscar in peril
as silly as the first film was it's
threats and ghosts were never presented
like jokes the whole movie was deadpan
as heck except for peter
but then the sequel tried to be in on
the humor much more
and it falls flat because while the
first film had jokes that didn't slow
down the scene
this one feels like the joke should have
a rim shot after every other line
maybe it's just my hang up but i say if
we're endangering a baby
this needs to be taken more seriously
throughout
definitely by peter if nothing else
he can still have his funny lines but
let's actually get the guy properly
emotionally invested here
so that leaves winston who after the
stupid party the film basically forgets
even exists until about halfway in
that was really stupid and i'm
not just bitter about that because
winston's my favorite ghostbuster
although
it's in the mix so for a revised
backstory this time winston is in a
similar boat to janine he stuck around
until the phone stopped ringing and now
he's found something else
but what we've actually got a lot of
freedom here because the first film
gives us
so few details about winston's
background all we know is that he's got
a fairly mercenary attitude
if there's a steady paycheck in it i'll
believe anything you say
but his qualifications could be almost
anything
heck early drafts of the script for the
first film
actually had winston being more
qualified than the rest of the team
a decorated air force background and
multiple phds
but at the end of the day winston has a
blue collar vibe and it feels more
organic to keep him working in that vein
so we are going to put him in city
construction
at the supervisor level you know
somebody who goes to the sites now and
then but isn't there every day doing the
grunt work
now this is going to allow us to bring
him into the story earlier than the film
currently does because
the guys are going gonna tap him when
they decide to tear up the road to
investigate the slime
so that's everybody's new starting
position not
massively different from the film as is
but tweaked in ways that make
a little more sense and since some of
these are now more organic
to the first film they require less time
to justify so overall
we're going to nickel and dime the
scenes that establish this stuff and
shave
somewhere between five and eight minutes
out of the first act
which is the act that drags the most out
of the film as is
inciting incident so another problem
we've got to deal with is how after the
tease with the baby carriage and the
looming threat
is established that threat exists almost
in parallel to the main characters with
their paths crossing out of sheer
coincidence i mean
if viggo hadn't just happened to
enthrall a guy who knew dana
and gone for her kids specifically the
ghostbusters might never have caught on
to him before it was too late
it is too much of the plot to pivot on
dumb luck so
this needs work here's what we're gonna
do along with the concerns about peter
not being as
present as a father as he should be
we're going to establish that dana has
been worried about oscar
since even before he was born we're not
going to overplay it this isn't a
hysterical overprotective mother thing
this is worried about how what happened
to her in the first film
might have impacted her son because of
how weird everything was
the woman was possessed and literally
turned into a hellhound
being concerned that her first kid's
words might be
doesn't sound like a completely
unreasonable fear so she's gonna get
antsy around supernatural stuff
especially when it comes to her kid
whereas peter's way more blase about it
as you'd expect from him
here's the thing dana she's right
we're going to establish that oscar
being chosen as viggo's vessel
is because the lingering spiritual
residue of what happened to dana makes
her child
more compatible with the entity like
vigo
it's like finding the ideal organ donor
now this is going to accomplish a couple
of things
it'll give us a pivot point for peter
where the story can properly
slap him across the face with the fact
that he has not been taking this
seriously enough
up to this point and it will eliminate
the dependence on coincidence
admittedly dana completely changing
careers so that she's restoring art in
the museum that vigo just happens to be
in
is a bit of a coincidence but you know
what if we button up these other things
i think we'll get away with that one
the mood slime
all right this is going to be a bit
tricky because this is not a terrible
idea it's just
handled very ham-fistedly and the
results few of the existing film's most
cringe-inducing moments
but structurally it's sound in terms of
establishing what needs to be known
about the mood slime and the pace that
it establishes it
there's a river of it under the city
getting doused in it instills a strong
emotional reaction
due to the standard mood of new york as
a city it's currently negatively charged
but it can be positively charged with
the right stimulus
that's what we need all that gets
covered at a good pace as far as where
in the film we learn each
piece of the puzzle but what's done to
establish some of these points is just
it's just not great material between the
weak sauce fight the team has and the
judge who is just cartoonish levels of
over the top
this needs a little massaging in each
scene
but nothing too tricky we'll keep the
dancing toaster because
it's cute and it establishes the
animated properties of the slime
okay let's talk about new characters
so to my way of thinking we've got three
new characters that
we need to talk about not counting vigo
who is uh kind of his own conversation
being the main villain
but we've got yamish
the mayor's aide hartemeyer and judge
wexler
i am not really a fan of any of these
three characters
janusz and wexler feel like cartoon
characters and heartamire is filling the
exact same role that walter peck did in
the first
one so he's part of the whole retreading
familiar ground problem
janice is also filling a bit of a repeat
role since he's effectively the
substitute lewis tully even though lewis
hasn't gone away
just like lewis in the first film he
orbits dana gets caught up in the
machinations of a big villain
is odd and a bit off-putting and
primarily played for laughs
but whereas lewis felt like a mild
exaggeration of the kind of person you
may have met somewhere along the line
yanish is overblown into this weird
flamboyant tool the kind that
only exists in movies and television but
despite my annoyances with him i'm not
actually going to change very much it
seems like everybody else
marks him as a highlight in the film so
i'm just going to have to shrug it off
and chalk it up to
i i don't get it i am however ditching
the ghost nanny kidnap thing because
even as a kid that confused the
absolute hell out of me is that just a
ghost
and if it is what does it look like
yamiche and if it is yanish
why can he suddenly turn into a ghost
and have like
ghost powers the most we saw before this
was his eyes glowed in one scene
but even if that is the case and i buy
that why doesn't he do anything like
this later
he doesn't use his powers to try and
stop the ghostbusters when they show up
the
heck would they just scrap it we'll
still get oscar kidnapped
but not like this doesn't even really
matter how just not like
this the judge also doesn't need to be
drastically altered in terms of his
story function he just needs to be toned
down
like way the hell down like about 90
percent
i know why it was done they wanted a big
explosive levels of
rage to get the mood slime really going
ballistic and we'll still have that
happen but rather than having it come
from
one rage-a-holic who is showing so much
bias on the bench
that his ruling is gonna be overturned
immediately on appeal
we're basically just gonna have the
whole courtroom get out of control
when the sentence is handed down fights
will break out between the people
supporting the ghostbusters and the
people who think that they're frauds
bailiffs will be tackling people it's
going to be chaos on the court and you
can still have it go over the top
with the judge as he bangs his devil and
shouts louder and louder for order
which would be a reasonable response
from a human being
as opposed to shouting how much you'd
like to burn the defendants at the stake
which is just stupid
so that leaves us with hardmeyer and
this one
is a little bit tough because there kind
of does need to be a barrier between the
mayor and the ghostbusters because if
they could just roll up and call in a
favor
things become too easy plus it makes
sense for a politician like lenny to
basically brush them off when it's no
longer to his political advantage to pay
attention to them so we need to keep
that element in play without him being
such a stand-in for [ __ ] who
i'll actually acknowledge i appreciate
that i'm not trying to shoehorn into
this film
let's just make him a bit less directly
confrontational a bit more sly
weasel and that might be enough
so
the climax the final confrontation as it
currently exists
doesn't have much going for it they're
mostly spraying slime
viggo's getting out of the painting it
should be a big moment but it's really
insubstantial and underwhelming
we don't have a proper sense of what
would happen if he succeeded in his
whole scheme i mean
yes he'd overtake oscar and that needs
to be taken seriously but
i mean on the grand threat scale here
would he just have been a baby because
that's not all that scary
so what we need we need a way to get
viggo out of the painting
with a bit more pomp and circumstance
than it just sort of
happening there needs to be a next level
moment
right now it doesn't exist when he comes
out of that frame
it needs to be threat raising this sort
of
oh crap we weren't ready for this
escalation
like what the appearance of stay puft
was in the first film
how we manage this is going to be a bit
tricky because
if viggo can get out of the painting
without possessing the baby
why doesn't he just do that in the first
place
so whatever he does needs to be a last
ditch
gambit something that will give him
direct agency in our world
but also make him more vulnerable
basically we're going to make him into a
glass cannon so that's the principle
what are the actual nuts and bolts
logistics of this
i don't really want him just possessing
somebody else because
the movie already does that
and it's stupid plus again if you can
possess anybody
why is he going after a baby in the
first place
but if the whole idea is that he's stuck
in the painting
how do we get him out in a way that is
distinct
from any other ghost that's been in
either this
film or the previous well here's my
angle
the canvas itself is supernaturally
imbued
it's not just holding vigo's essence
it's protecting him
it's armor we're gonna make that literal
imagine the portrait
pushing forward like there's something
on the other side pressing against it
heck the film even teases that at the
front end but it never pays off
we're gonna go the next step and when
viggo comes out the canvas
comes with him so it tears away from the
frame
wraps around this nebulous entity that
viggo con currently is
and the cgi at the time was just far
enough along that i think
they actually would have been viable to
pull this off
and you remember how big that painting
was so we've got something like
a 15 foot tall vigo that it's totally
cool to have an uncanny valley effect
going on because
his body is a two-dimensional picture
stretched over his supernatural essence
the way in which this makes him more
vulnerable is that it's not
how the painting was intended to be used
as protection
so it's less stable and the protection
it grants him
is spottier now this may sound
complicated but i
don't think that establishing these
rules is going to be very difficult
the nature of the canvas and the frame
themselves being kind of armor that
protects
vigo that can be established at almost
any point
after the ghostbusters know that viggo's
the problem
and the details of it being weaker with
this unintended use and being out of the
frame
it's easy enough to drop in as just an
egon explains line
the cartoon version of ghostbusters did
this all the time
now look at them closely see each time
they fire
they weaken of course a little clunky
maybe but it gets the job done and if we
set it up right it'll only need that one
line for coverage
oh quick sidebar the whole thing where
lewis gets a ride from slimer
and then he thinks he's the one who
brought down the ghostly force bubble
yeah we are
cutting all of that because it's stupid
and it's not funny and it's an objective
scientific fact that i don't like it
so we've got a pitch battle with an
enemy who's simultaneously more
dangerous and more vulnerable we don't
want it to drag on too long
because i'm not sure there are too many
ways to keep it interesting for more
than a couple minutes
but it's solid escalation of the
situation and will lend itself to a much
more dynamic climax the only question is
how does he get put down in the very end
yes i know he gets weakened by the
people singing outside and
much time i should grin i have to admit
this place better than i remember
because
it's new years people would be singing
with optimism and hope
and their heart so fine but that'll only
sort of lock them up for a moment or two
and give an opening
we need more than that if the canvas
is armor now the blasters aren't going
to do much unless it gets properly
cracked open
and the person who's gonna do that
is dana a couple of reasons for this and
yes i will admit part of it is that i
have a massive crush on sigourney
weaver she can do badass like a freaking
boss
and it is a crime that they just tie her
up in the movie as
is but it's not just
that it's also about peter peter has
been the glory hound right from the
first film he got into this business
for the fame and the fortune so what i
want from him is for him to prioritize
protecting oscar and if you forgot
as presented he currently leaves
the baby alone to go and fight the bad
guy
we need the literal opposite of that i
want him to die for his son
scoop him up hold him close and to duck
behind cover and
stay there to comfort his child and
trust
that his teammates can take care of the
baddie and
i want dana to see him
do this have a quick moment where she
recognizes that he can protect oscar
well enough on his own and she can rely
on him and then
she springs into action how does she do
it well
she's been working on paint restoration
in this very room she knows
what's here while the other ghostbusters
are desperately trying to figure out how
to get their proton packs to break
through the canvas
and it's not working dana goes for the
tools at hand
paint thinner cutting tools she throws
the paint thinner onto the canvas it's
like holy water to a vampire and she
goes in
to cut a gash on the canvas before
either retreating or being knocked back
she can do this while viggo's weakened
by the singing the ghostbusters
they get a blaster into that opening
pull viggo's spirit out through it
leaving the husk of the canvas
to fall on the floor like an empty body
bag while viggo gets trapped and tagged
like the uppity ghost he ultimately
is we can even have a moment where his
voice echoes out of the trap
about how he's too great and powerful to
be
beaten like this you can have a nice put
down line
about how he is no better than anything
else they ever faced
he just used more cheap tricks knocking
the bastard down a peg is to me
just flat out more rewarding and that
that just about does it for ghostbusters
two
two in the box ready to go we'd be fast
and
baby slow wow
so there you have it the things i would
do in order to fix
ghostbusters 2 without doing a page 1
rewrite of the entire thing
would it have been as good as the first
one if they did it this way
well no not to me anyway but
it would have been far less of a letdown
and of course
it would still all be execution
dependent
i didn't even talk about how much the
music
hurts that second film compared to the
first because
oh you know music clips they get flagged
way more aggressively than film but the
first film was it was ominous and
haunting the second one it was this
light and bouncy it was just
it was one more tonal disaster to add to
the pile but
i think i think i've done enough for
today
now this video doesn't have a sponsor so
instead i want to shout out another
creator that i think
folks should check out this time it's a
cosplayer by the name of night
mage who i was lucky enough to meet in
person at last year's terrificon
he's really personable his work is
incredible and his instagram is an
absolute joy to behold so go
and check him out i also want to note
that this video would not
have been possible without the backing
of my patreon supporters and if
you want to see bigger productions like
this
from me lending your support will help
make that happen plus
also you know i'll be able to eat but
what do you think about the changes i
suggested do you share my complaints
about ghostbusters 2
do you think i actually would have made
it worse how would you have done it
differently whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
usual stuff like subscribe share this
around all of that is
an immense help but you you really don't
have to
if you don't want to because end of the
day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye